jaws good morning thanks for joining us
did you ever have a teammate who was out
of control couldn't help himself first
of all Dan great to be with you once
again and happy holidays to you and your
listeners and how much time do we have
because I could prob go through a
listing of players that were nothing but
a pain in the butt so it's something you
have to deal it but you have this at
Duke where you have a really talented
player in Grayson Allen team captain and
that's the third time he's been caught
trippin somebody like it what do you do
I mean they're going to take away
playing time from him and that usually
is the one that gets everybody's
attention but I don't even know if
that's going to work well you certainly
hope it works and Mike sous-chefs key is
one of the great coaches in the history
of college basketball he knows how to
deal with his players and the one thing
that does hurt players at any level is
not being on the court you want to play
or you want to be on the field that's
why you're getting involved with sports
to compete and everyone loves the
competition but there's always a fine
line and certainly Grayson is now
overstepped at that fine line for the
third time yeah I look at that replay
about 50 times this morning and you can
see it was it was a clear trip no once
this the offensive player got by him he
clearly reached out and tripped him so
there's a fine line between being
competitive and doing stupid things and
it you know coach cable handle that it
reminds me of and domick ensue he can't
really help himself vontaze burfict
seems to be caught in this draymond
Green with the Golden State Warriors
they're just players who just can't help
themselves that there's somehow involved
in something dan there a lot of players
like that I'm in and I wasn't joking i
said i could probably spend your whole
show talking about guys and the way you
whip yourself up into a frenzy before
you go on the field and football might
be a little bit different because of the
violent nature of the game and the
physical nature of the game you know
I've seen guys punch lockers before they
walk on the bill Lily punch them with
their hand I've seen guys put their
helmet on in front of me before going on
the field and bang
head against a concrete wall to see
stars before they go on the field this
is what guys do to get themselves ready
to go out and compete at the highest
level and it's sometimes hard to control
these guys he's Ron Jaworski the NFL
analyst for the mothership what do you
think NFL scouts coaches GM's are going
to do when it comes to the name Joe
Mixon at Oklahoma with his NFL future
with first-round talent as running back
yeah it's probably not necessarily going
to be the the pro scouted the these the
type of situation where team owners get
involved you know what is your
philosophy as far as dealing with
players that have a checkered past so
you know he's obviously great very high
he's a talented football player but this
goes way up the food chain and it may
even end up at the commissioner's office
you know these are the types of things
where the league literally has to sign
off before you say this a guy you want
in our league or on any team in our
league this game tonight I know when the
Eagles started off and started off
strong I cautioned everybody to say it's
it shouldn't be this easy for Carson
wins and they haven't played anybody now
we've sort of seen everybody fall back
to you know back to earth here what
should say about Carson Wentz what's
happening you know the last 10 weeks 11
weeks well the Carson Wentz is going to
be a superstar in this league there
there is absolutely no doubt in my mind
and I felt that when I went out to Fargo
and watch his pro day and spend time
with him his coaches the people in the
North Dakota State University program a
great program by the way this kid has
got all the talent you know he's been
asked to do far too much as the Eagles
quarterback know couple weeks ago
dropping back 63 times with limited
offensive weapons and and he's been
asked to lead this team as a rookie and
no rookie is you know ever going to step
into an NFL huddle and be the leader of
the football team and he's been asked to
do that I think he's done an admiral
Merle job he certainly has all the towns
you go watch him you could see all the
throws you see the movement the arm
strength the accuracy and he will get
better there are still things that he
needs to tweak in his game his mechanics
are flawed sometimes he needs to be more
consistent is throwing slot his footwork
in his upper body that
all come with a good offseason of NFL
coaching any Oh Frank Reich is in
Philadelphia John deeply pose with
quarterbacks coach they've got good
coaches now what they have to do is with
a quarterback position being a dependent
position dance you depend on other
people he needs a better supporting cast
as far as wide receivers go if you swap
Carson wins in dak Prescott what would
be the story probably about the same I I
think both are terrific quarterback
saying that dak Prescott was probably a
bigger surprise but he went into an
unbelievably great position in Dallas
you know arguably the league's best
offensive line they take a Z kial
Elliott at number 4 they've got a
tremendous possession receiver and Jason
Witten to control the hash area you
gotta Dez Bryant a cold Beasley who is
one of the guys that's been one of the
unsung heroes of this season you throw
to this guy he catches about it every
time you target if he catches about nine
out of ten so he's the guy that is
literally uncomfortable so when I look
at Prescott the situation was perfect
for him he got lucky when Tony Romo went
down but I think clearly believe a guy
like like Carson Wentz could have gone
in that situation and played just as
well we have this discussion yesterday
you can have a zekiel Elliott or lay
beyond Bell Wow oh that's real easy III
will say this I when I watched it Zeke
coming out last year and study this tape
but I thought he was the best player
coming out last year so I'm not
surprised Dallas Cowboys felt that
highly about him and but you know most
teams are devaluing running backs over
the last few years but this guy is
special and and the reason i really like
not only the running ability to
receiving ability his ability to pick up
the Blitz and that is so critical the
NFL level you know to be smart
intelligent to read where those
linebackers and safeties and slants and
stunts and twists are coming from he's
an intelligent player that can block so
to me he's kind of the complete package
I would probably lean slightly towards
Ezekiel Elliott yeah here is our other
discussion Odell Beckham jr. or Julio
Jones I'm
Leo Jones guy and I think Odell Beckham
is a tremendous tremendous player but
when you watch Julio Jones I think on a
consistent basis he's much more of a
contributor and it's clear that there's
a special chemistry that Matt Ryan and
Julio Jones have that is tough to defend
and I think you know Beckham you know
for all the great plays that he does
make in the great town he has sometimes
it disappears for a while in games all
right here's another one for you I know
why Jon Gruden would stay broadcasting
tell me why he would leave to take the
Rams Joan it's real simple he you know
he loves football and he loves coaching
and you know i can almost equate it to
the you know the Dick Vermeil you know
Dick Vermeil stayed out 15 years before
he came back and end up winning a Super
Bowl and you know I talked to Coach
reveal on a regular basis almost weekly
and when when you love the game of
football like a dick for me love the
game and the Jon Gruden loves the game
you know if there's a part of you that
always wants to get back in there and a
I don't know what John's gonna do I know
how much he loves his job at ESPN he's
absolutely phenomenal at what he does
but there's something there's there's
some unfulfillment see I can't go back
and play I'm done but if your cup if
you're a coach you go back and coach
yeah yeah that I think that that that
fire always burns but he has to be in
love with Jared Goff though well III
think any cut it quite honestly Dan I
think any quarterback you know that is
on a team that a coach is looking to
come to it's gotta be a guy you believe
in and you know we all know this a
quarterback driven game it gives you
your best percentage chance of being
successful and any coach that looks at a
coaching opportunity you want to
evaluate the quarterback and i know john
for his quarterback camp you know he
loves Jared Goff he loved Carson Wentz
you know me so those are guys I know
that were very high in his platform in
regards to guys he'd eventually like
coach Josh good to talk to you and have
fun tonight with the Eagles in the
Giants tell Sal and Merrill that we
settle oh we love doing that show the
match up so don't miss the folks it's
the best acts as a no show you'll ever
see thank you John thanks Dan happy
holidays you too
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]